Speaker 1: . Big, big news.
Joe Biden yesterday came out in full support
of lifting patent protections on coronavirus
vaccines to help produce more vaccines globally.
The Biden administration said that we need
a breakthrough for international vaccination.
Vaccination happening quite well in the United
States and well in a few other countries.
But there are lots of countries that don't
even have vaccines on the immediate horizon
right now.
And Joe Biden has now said, let's do it, let's
suspend intellectual property protections
to ramp up vaccine production.
And this is something Joe Biden has been increasing.
Lee, under pressure to say it's not doesn't
appear to be something Joe Biden can actually
do, but the reasoning is clear.
We have a global health crisis.
These are extraordinary circumstances.
We need to produce as many doses as quickly
as possible.
And this would be a case where while you can
respect conceptually intellectual property
protections and patents and copyright, you
can make the case this particular situation
warrants lifting those protections.
Now, I have to tell you, for me, there are
two stories here.
First of all.
Is the story that Joe Biden is being pushed
left, I mean, at this point on paper, this
may be the most progressive administration
in history.
I, I we have to understand what we're comparing
to.
But this is something that Big Pharma was
completely against.
They got expensive lobbyists pushing for it
not to be done, for there to be no lifting
of patents.
And while Joe Biden can't actually do it,
Biden standing up to them and saying this
should be done is a really big deal.
If you look at Joe Biden's position on health
care, it's to the left of Obama.
If you look at Joe Biden's position on taxation,
it's to the left of Obama.
On paper, this may be the most progressive
administration in history.
Now, we've never had you know, Bernie has
never been president.
So we have to understand what that means.
For those who said Joe Biden could not be
pushed left, he clearly has been, at least
to some degree.
Now, here's my concern about this entire vaccine
thing, that vaccine patent thing.
I agree that the patents should be lifted.
I agree that as many places as possible should
be given whatever they need to start manufacturing
vaccines as quickly as possible.
There's no question whatsoever.
That being said.
I don't think the lifting of patents is actually
going to get us out of this mess, why?
In researching what it would take for places
that are not yet producing vaccines to start
producing vaccines, you could be looking at
two years of time to build the infrastructure
to produce vaccines if you start today.
So while I agree that the patents should be
lifted and there are reasons for the future,
that it would be great to set that precedent
in a global pandemic and all.
I'm with it.
I'm with you.
I think this is a great thing that Joe Biden
has said.
If it takes two years to build the infrastructure,
if you don't have it to start producing vaccines,
if you start today and who could start today,
you've got to find locations.
You have to figure out where are these factories
going to go if it takes four months to start
and then it takes two years to do and then
the entire vaccine production and distribution
would take several more months.
We are looking at new vaccine production.
If patents are lifted today, that wouldn't
deliver vaccines until the end of twenty,
twenty three.
It's just too late.
I don't want to be a party pooper.
I don't want to rain on anybody's parade.
But it's not clear to me that this is anything
more than at least for the next two years,
a theoretical or academic question.
It should be done.
And for the future pandemic.
I'm with it again.
I'm with it.
Please, please don't write to me saying, David,
how dare you be against it?
No, I'm for it.
But when I see all these people on Facebook
saying we could just get out of this if the
vaccine patents were lifted, Moderna did say
it won't enforce its patent.
There's other aspects of the production that
Moderna doesn't control which have intellectual
property protections.
I get that.
I just don't see how this gets us out of the
pandemic any sooner.
If I'm missing something, let me know the
right decision.
I don't actually think it will get vaccines
into people's arms any sooner for this pandemic.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Quick break.
Great show today